Humanity has always hunted for knowledge
in the unknown
the Wonder is
not that the field of stars is so vast
that we have measured it
[Music]
yeah
we're all here because we're committed
to the biggest question of all what's
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
we do not fully understand all that is
at work here no final group in the stars
to be unraveling this mystery
here on out to Captain grab jump is
ready I love this park
these artifacts could be everything
we've been looking for another great
secret the universe is asking us to
unravel
settlement throughout the Galaxy could
be at risk
we are not stopping whatever lies at the
end of this road
hope change Humanity
forever
This Is Where We Belong
[Music]
[Applause]